you know I must tell you there's
something very weird and strange about
jean-claude carrière look up his credits
and you'll find he has writing credits
on 139 films among them Belle de Jour
the tin drum this discrete charm of the
bourgeoisie the Diary of a chambermaid
that obscure object of desire and the
list goes on and on of all his 20 while
actually was at 35 year collaboration
with Louis spun well the great Louis
been well jean-claude wrote the
screenwriter had better work with the
one who was making the film in order to
reach the point where they're working on
the same film I calculated he said that
boon well and I ate together just the
two of us more than two thousand times
which is much more than many couples can
say not quite so lucky as boon well I
calculate that we ate together only
hundreds of times while making the
Unbearable Lightness of being together
with Saul Zaentz
we scouted alternatives for Prague where
we were not allowed to shoot back in the
Bay Area we hung out every day we even
lived together at times we became a
couple
I remember soaking side-by-side in
Calistoga baths mud up to our chins
trying to unravel Milan Kundera's novel
and gain insight into the womanizer
Tomas played by Daniel day-lewis after
the mud baths wild to young masseuses
firmly plied out what plied their trade
we discovered Thomas's two lovers we
discussed Tomas as two lovers Juliette
Binoche
lena olin jean claude asked me if I were
Tomas which would be my first choice too
I chose one and jean-claude vehemently
disagreed
it's not easy something teaching
something about sex to a Frenchman later
back at my office my company is called
walrus and associates because I had made
a film with walruses in it the argument
continued the more heated I became the
more quiet he became he was just
scribbling furiously on a notepad then
jean-claude showed me the notepad well
I'd been while I'd been rampaging the
guy had been drawing cartoons a series
of walruses two big fat naked walruses
smoking cigars pontificating like big
shots arguing about how to come up with
a hit movie two walruses bickering over
the meaning of Unbearable Lightness of
being squabbling over walruses sexual
preferences well his cartoons
transformed our mood and magically our
stalemate was broken and suddenly we
knew we were working together on the
same film
now we could agree that Tomas could make
love to both women that's when I found
out that for many years John Claude had
made a living as a professional
cartoonist and for many many years he'd
been a prolific novelist film critic and
tireless essayist one novel about
Einstein and recently with Umberto Eco
he wrote this is not the end of the book
he's also closely collaborated with his
wife the brilliant iranian-born scholar
Nahal who has a doctorate in Chinese and
has helped immerse him in the Eastern
cultures Manichaeism Sufism and all and
all that stuff
and she was with jean-claude when he
worked with his friend the Dalai Lama
their twelve-year-old daughter Chiara
could not make it but says salut Papa
even Evo two's a Hollywood his late wife
a ghost an artist was of great help to
me and my producer son Peter in the
making of Henry in June his daughter
Rhys our friend from that time is here
tonight and I have just discovered that
is a Reese's birthday and this is a very
nice party for youî Rees 139 films then
consider that he's acted in 32 films and
he's directed three films one of which a
short film he did with Pierrette X
called happy Anniversary won an Oscar
he's an officer of the Legion of Honor
Frances highest honor
then consider calculate with me add in
the more than 30 years he spent in the
theater collaborating primarily with the
great Peter Brook on many productions
like the spectacular nine-hour
Mahabharata consider how much time he
now spends touring the world over with
his own one-man version of the
Mahabharata where he plays the ageless
storyteller vyas ax when you consider
all the work he's done and I haven't
mentioned everything not by a longshot
and when you think about how much time
it would take any of us his fellow
seasoned pros to do all that he has done
and when you calculate the hours the
years the meals the women the wear and
tear did I mention the women
and when you're in his presence and feel
how remarkably energetic and vigorous he
is what dawns on you what's weird about
him and scary is that he strangely liked
that immortal sage he portrays the one
who wrote the Mahabharata and then
consider that by any human calculation
I've done the math over and over this
enlightened one this guy who comes to us
disguised as jean-claude carrière has
got to be at least at the very least 143
years old it's about time we gave him an
Oscar